hello and welcome to this video playing
Mohammed 1763 that's not the reading
he's much higher rated so let's see
probably get your ratty opening and we
do okay yeah this is a very natural
looking setup with Bishop to d6 White
has an interesting way to play here with
92l oh I know it looks a bit odd but the
idea is to play E 4 and the Knights
support that very nicely so here we go
yeah interesting probably Bishop c7 or
it goes to e7 so what's happening here
probably Knight f6 is the best is the
next move so maybe put this here 90 f6 I
dropped back to c3 I don't want to trade
as usual the black problem here is the
c8 Bishop as usual means as usual in
Queens gambit declined structures it's
just this eternal problem how to get
this bishop into the game if black
solves this problem then he is fine
usually interesting him wonder if this
is an idea it's a bit weird maybe or a
little bit non-standard but just keep
this tension and play Queen e2 next if
he takes it now the pawn on e5 will be
very uncomfortable let's say to play
against
then my next move was most likely
Queenie too if he keeps the tension yeah
I did so Queenie - probably
I wonder if c5 is his ATM maybe I'm
quite happy with this if he plays it I
would have taken and maybe nice b5 there
is an interesting choice the bishop to
be form Jim I'm not sure what he wants
to do does he want to take one does he
prepare Knight to d7 okay a move that is
interesting here is c5 this is just ya
shutting down any c5 ideas okay he's got
the d5 square but that is not super
important him taking would be a huge
positional error so I don't think he's
going to do that it opens up the B file
it allows me to play c4 later to control
d5 so taking is not a good idea
if he goes 95 machina that she's wrong
that is the kind of move that you can
only play if you think the alternatives
are like downright lost or something
something very dramatically worse
because here you're getting young that
is really really uncomfortable I was
actually inaccurate I'm not much but 90
- if he goes 95 I have to cover the pawn
and then after f6 I have to go Bishop d6
okay it's not a problem
that's our problem actually yeah so what
are you doing now there is no b6s no
bishop t 7s Andrew could be eight black
is running out of moves yeah
constructive move that same we can play
whatever King h8 but it doesn't solve
any problem yeah this one so sit and sit
and wait move okay I was briefly
thinking he might have any five
I mean it's desperation but still okay
Knight will come to f5 I think I'm just
going to increase the pressure on it six
now after yes plate f6 that makes a lot
of sense come on make a move no I don't
know I said sometimes it's a bit weird
how people handle the increment I mean
you read you really should never lose on
time I mean you can definitely do some
time if you have if both are down and
you just like have to make just down on
the increment and then all of a sudden
the problem appears and you simply don't
see a move that doesn't immediately lose
that can happen of course but I mean
okay their position is very bad for
black but you can still just sit and
wait and hope for hope for a miracle so
this line here is I think quite quite
nice for white I went here you can also
play Knight c3 first but this is not bad
9 ft 2 group e8 Knight to c3 yeah here's
this option to play e5 but that is not
yeah strategically very desirable
a kewpie position that you get is not
like after this it's not great
can I be 3 9 f 3 months I think quite
careful white
so he went 97 and deform Jan and now
this is already uncomfortable but this
is I mean it's just not a great line
that like played here but should be 7
Bishop f4 just preventing any five idea
Knight f6 Knight c3 I don't want to
trade the engine gives trading and
Bishop e5 yam it's an advantage but
generally speaking don't trade if you
have that much more space we should be 5
now it's the best move okay
at least that's what stopped Fischer
skimming here so I wasn't entirely
certain during the game but I think it
makes all the sense you don't want to
trade that is not really helping at all
and there should be three he might have
if I'm them so I have to do it
Queen is 7 Queen e2 it's all very normal
yeah now you have wide range of good
moves
anything is basically good at c5 it's a
very straightforward approach you just
prevent black complain c5 ever and he
has to lose more time actually this is
the only reasonable way to play this and
white is better but it continued that
that is strategically surrendering
basically the engine is on +2 it's not a
surprise
even though it is an materially equal
position will create all kind of normal
moves TM f6 now I can switch to the e6
pawn that is the nature of those cramped
positions and the person who has no
space has to regal sell out and
sometimes plays pawn moves that give the
attacker additional
ideas though here on he lost some time
which is really not not that it's not
necessary in a way you can still
continue to play this yeah I play Queen
f7 and then just yeah hope that white is
not yeah playing it right yeah anyway I
think it's a good display how to play
the white side of Catalan structures
thanks a lot for watching